thanks Yasser alireza first of all
congratulations a big victory for you
yesterday you came to the studio you
seemed a little bit disappointed but
also hopeful because you felt like the
dust is off the shoulders and finally
you're starting to play some clear chest
do you feel like that yeah I think um
Mike as I said yesterday my game
throughout the tournament is decent
level I think just my results were not
good and now I'm happy that I got this
win he's very solid player with white
and it's kind of impossible to beat him
with black and I'm really happy to get
this one definitely a solid player but
he's been struggling in this event
outside of that minus one also his
positions haven't been that good was
that part of your strategy and did you
try to complicate matters early on in
this game yeah last year also for
instance he was in a lot of losing
position and he was getting out of it
very good he was losing his Meme and he
was defending very well so that's kind
of his style and of course he has to
improve his tail but
um yeah for me today my plan was to just
play solid with black and yeah I didn't
try it for instance last year I played
this year I just wanted for me draw was
okay draw was okay okay
um if he wants to force things with
white I cannot do much so let's talk
about the game because uh yeah he choose
the most solid line that there is in
love with white except she takes D5 and
I said he wants to make a quick draw but
I I played a tricky move with Bishop
before to not allow him to go for E4
which is also okay Bishop E7 E4 because
this is your preparation without you
don't have to read I don't think it was
my I don't I just remember if there is
this possibility but I I didn't prepare
this because everything is okay here
yeah so he played this and suddenly he
got very aggressive before but I think
it's a good move but I think there is no
need I think just rookie one Rook D1
also but before it's a good move and
here he has to go for E4 because as we
saw in the game Knight B6 if I get is
not good then here I think I'm just okay
after it takes takes takes some Castle
on Knight F6 P5 play normal game yeah
it's very equal so equal yeah yeah so so
he was definitely getting ambitious yeah
I think he just
um miscalculated something I don't know
because normally you would not go for
this one sacrifice to take it back again
and for me it was weird I think like
maybe he missed Knight B6 BC DC I don't
know yeah because normally either you go
for E4 here or you don't go this to this
line to take back the opponent cars yeah
yeah
um so at this point you are already
starting to get some hopes of maybe you
know getting a game at least yeah of
course but still it was a bit risk to go
for this because I was not sure of for
instance this plan before and for
because my Bishop is on C7 it can be
dangerous e594 but I like to it I I like
the fact that it's complicated finally
we get to play some jazz right and it
definitely felt that way uh let's keep
going he's trying to equalize so at this
point you felt like he was trying to
find the equality in the position
A5 you got everything got out of hand
for him I think because he missed the
plan of season three but he played
perfectly I think here
Knight C5 and he color is probably here
but yeah this Knight D2 was very
important I think my only chance
and
it's funny Gary it was in the city and
we were watching your game and he was
saying that you're really trying to give
back the pawn but in a creative way to
get some yeah exactly because this Pawn
was going anyway because it's not
defended by the end so yeah yeah E5 was
not so good because I missed E4
is just brilliant and I think I have to
go to take the bishop and then push E5
and here maybe I'm better a bit but this
is still very dry it looks very yeah I
wanted to make things still complicated
but
it could have packed for it of course
it takes yeah Bishop B2 I saw I was
confused why he didn't go Bishop Beetle
here actually
okay maybe 97 yeah
yes so it takes probably missed Bishop
before yeah Queen C3 I was I was like
hoping he just doesn't go for it because
so you saw this movie yeah of course I
saw this movie because first I saw this
this line I'm just lost here 96 and
everything collapses yeah I was just
praying that there's a sequence it trade
because I bluffed the bishop before
and it works but you know practical
chess is also important right and at
this point he only had 12 minutes for a
lot of moves they left him before you
reached yeah Queen C3 is not easy not
easy yeah and you have so many moves
that you can play right maybe Queen A1
even and he was also still in the mood
to make equality I mean he was not
thinking about Advantage I think that's
a good point yeah so here Queen G5 I was
trying to be practical I was not
yeah Knights yet here he had 30 seconds
yeah yeah um I cannot explain what I
mean because he's under a lot of
pressure with time so but yeah this King
G2 Queen F3 is a solid plan yeah but he
plundered
here Rook D1
it was better
is a bit crazy to take on King G2
to
and what if before and he could take
five
yeah let's take Rook takes
you could take
it was I thought I'm winning here but
he's
oh yeah
is that it
should be streamed it should be three
not 96. yes
yeah yeah yeah okay I missed this but
he's he has 30 seconds here so
thanks yeah in here it's gone I think
it's already gone yeah a big victory
especially with the black pieces never
an easy uh feature uh congratulations
and good luck in the rest of your games
thank you Christian good luck